je dois dire que c'est évidemment un des
côtés difficile de votre métier en même
temps c'est que votre vie privée
le spectateur essai de la connaître le
plus possible de vous suivre
quand ils écrivent des lettres à par
l'admiration que j'ai pour debout comme
artiste au musée pour toi ils racontent
leur vie à eux donc ça l'être humain
qu'il se
ils ont de nous faire participer leurs
propres vies mais en même temps une
semaine un peu à la vôtre ah oui à sa ma
vie il leur appartiennent ah ben c'est
complètement et je pense que en 1967 qui
a été une année très difficile pour vous
et très dramatique
le public a suivi tout ce qui vous
arrive est et le public enfin vous le
savez ça tout le monde a suivi les
choses qui vous sont arrivés avec avec
beaucoup de coeur beaucoup beaucoup
d'indulgence beaucoup de peine et ça
prouve l'amitié que tout le monde vous
porte
nous allons venir justement cette année
67 tenez voici la chanson suivante elle
nous amène à une séance du palmarès des
chansons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
deux ans
les choses
santé
l'outil
lots non à rénover
m
je la chante mais je ne vous fais
[Musique]
m
et toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
du lourd
c'est une sage et la chambre c'est la
seule difficulté est gérée contre quand
on chante on ne va pas les sentiments
mais vous disiez tout à l'heure que pour
le public les sanctions s'accroche
souvent à des des souvenirs de leur vie
à des moments moins existence et pour
vous aussi bien sur les chansons qu'ils
soient à franchir à les soutenir
par contre si c'est mon travail
[Musique]
l'ajustement pendant cette vierge la
guerre au drame antique de mes produits
et puis l'état de vous écrire a dit
evans et beaucoup d'affection en matière
est cela qui m'a tant que le plus dur
est fait
[Musique]
dans cette maison
jeunes
non
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et tout ça
[Musique]
voyez-vous dalida dans la mesure où nous
racontions avec vous dalida d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui nous semblait difficile de
passer cette chanson là sous silence est
ce que vous voulez que nous supprimions
ce passage de l'émission non pourquoi
c'est quelque chose qui existe pourquoi
l'assumer en contre il ya des choses qui
vous qui vous enrichissent beaucoup
moment qu'on arrive à penser que la
souffrance qui ne souffraient pas
n'apprend pas donc des fois il est
nécessaire je pense que vous avez
beaucoup appris à ce moment là j'espère
[Musique]